شنت الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه سلسله
غارات على مناطق متفرقه وسط قطاع غزه
وافاد مراسل الجزيره بان احدى الغارات
استهدفت خيمه تؤوي نازحين غرب بلده
الزوايده ما اسفر عن استشهاد واصابه عدد
من المواطنين بينهم اطفال
ونساء لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
والله غير الحجم كل من قال السبب امام
الله راحوا كل شرته طردنا من الضرب من غزه
وجينا ه عز
قصفوا كل اودي ليش هم اللي بيحاربوا اودي
بخيمه قاعدين قاعدين بخيمه يا ناس الحلال
والله بخيمه يا الله بخيمه شردنا سيبنا
العماره وجينا شردين عشان الامان لا حول
ولا قوه الا بالله حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل
راحت بنتي وراحوا اودي وراحوا بناتي كلهم
وابني الكبير كلهم لا حول ولا قوه الا
بالله ما تزعليش يابا هيني بس تزعليش
خليكي قويه وين نور
[موسيقى]
يا يا
الحمد سنه لسه مات البنت
ياعود علي الله ود كمان جو واهم كمان يا
رب لا اله الا انت وحدك لا شريك
لك احنا منغ
هنا يشتغل
شغل